- [Instructor] Sue is a software engineer.
She wants to create a large scale drawing
of a processor inside a cell phone.
The processor is a square chip,
nine millimeters on each side.
Draw the processor such that one unit
on the grid below represents
one half of a millimeter.
All right, so let's just
think about these two worlds.
You have the drawing,
and you have the chip in the real world.
The drawing, we're thinking in terms
of these units here on this graph paper,
so units.
And the chip, we're thinking
in terms of millimeters.
And so we can set up a table here.
And they tell us draw
it such that one unit
represents half a millimeter.
So one unit would represent
one half of a millimeter.
They tell us that the processor
is nine millimeters on each side.
So that is how many times
as many millimeters?
Well, to go from one half to nine,
you have to multiply by 18.
So that's going to be 18
times as many units as well.
So if I want to do a scale
drawing right over here,
it's going to be a square.
It's a square chip.
And since the scale is one unit,
it represents half a millimeter.
18 units would represent nine millimeters,
and so I would want to
do 18 units on a side.
So one,
two, three,
four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine,
10, 11,
12, 13,
14, 15,
16, 17, 18.
So that would be the
left side of the chip.
Let me just see if I can
draw a straight line there,
just like that.
And then it would also be 18 wide,
18 units wide,
representing nine millimeters
in the real world.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12,
13, 14,
15, 16,
17, 18.
This is making my eyes hurt.
All right, so just like that,
and then I could draw
the other parts of it.
It would be like that,
and then I would just go
straight down like that.
And there you have it,
I have drawn a scale
drawing of our processor,
and we are all done.